espero que ahora ya sepamos un poquito
más acerca de las variables y como vimos
en el vídeo anterior las variables se
pueden designar a través de cualquier
símbolo aunque usualmente usamos letras
pues estamos acostumbrados a escribir
con ellas así podríamos usar x y z a b o
inclusive podríamos usar letras griegas
como theta cualquier símbolo puede
usarse de tal manera que al verlo puedes
detectar que es una variable puede tener
múltiples valores pero de todos estos el
que más típicamente representa una
variable es la letra x aunque los demás
se usan de alguna manera pero dado que
la letra x es la que se usa comúnmente
esto tiene un pequeño inconveniente el
problema es que la x se parece mucho al
símbolo multiplicación que usamos en
aritmética así si queremos escribir dos
por tres esto se escribe como dos por
tres pero ahora que estamos usando
variables si quisiera escribir por
ejemplo dos por equis lo escribiría de
la siguiente manera dos por equis
observa que el símbolo de x y la x son
muy similares
es precisamente el problema y si no
tenemos cuidado con el tamaño de la
letra no sabríamos lo que esto significa
significa 2 por x ó 2 x x que significa
en realidad esto y dado que esto es
confuso esto de aquí es confuso y puede
malinterpretarse evitamos a toda costa
usar
este símbolo para designar
multiplicaciones en álgebra en vez de
eso tenemos varias opciones en álgebra
para indicar multiplicación una de ellas
es por ejemplo si queremos indicar 2 por
x lo indicaremos como 2 punto x es
importante aclarar que este punto no es
un punto decimal este lo escribimos
ligeramente más alto y lo escribimos así
para no confundirnos entre esto y estos
símbolos que designan variables pero
esto sí lo podemos interpretar como 2
por x así por ejemplo si alguien nos
dice cuánto es 2 x cuando x es igual a 3
pues esto es exactamente lo mismo a 2 x
cuando x es igual a 3
la manera de escribir de esto es 2 y la
equis la ponemos entre paréntesis
después del 2 esto también significa 2
por x de nueva cuenta si en este caso x
fuera 7 esto sería 2 por 7 ó 14 pero la
manera más tradicional de hacerlo es
escribir la x justo después del 2 y esto
se va a leer como 2x pero esto de hecho
significa 2 por equis y aquí podrás
preguntar cómo es que esto no lo hicimos
acá arriba bueno si lo hubiéramos hecho
aquí pero si hubiéramos escrito esto
como 2 3 bueno esto más que 2 por 3
indica el número 23 por eso nunca lo
hacemos así pero aquí que estamos usando
una letra es claro que esto no es parte
del número
esto no es 20 algo esto significa 2 por
equis así es que estas tres representan
lo mismo 2 por x 2 por x 2 por equis
habiendo visto esto hagamos algunos
ejemplos algunos ejercicios para que
practiques esto y que te vayas
preparando para ejemplos posterior
si tenemos 10 menos
3 y queremos saber cuánto vale esto
cuando ya es igual a 2 bueno donde hay
es sustituimos por 2 así es que tenemos
que es igual a 2 aquí hay una y vamos a
sustituirlo por 2 esto nos va a dar 10
menos 3 por 2
aquí recordemos que la multiplicación
tiene precedencia sobre la resta así es
que esto sería 3 por 2 6 y 10 menos 6 10
6 es igual a 4 hagamos otro supongamos
que tenemos no sé a ver vamos a hacer
supongamos que tenemos 7 7 x 7 x
- 4 déjame hacerlo con otro color 7 x
menos 4 y queremos evaluar eso cuando x
cuando x es igual a 3 entonces donde
veamos x sustituimos por 3
así es que aquí tenemos 7
el original 7 port y voy a usar esta
anotación que se puede usar con números
esto sería 7 por 3 7 por 3 menos 4 y de
nueva cuenta la multiplicación tiene
precedencia sobre la suma y la resta así
es que esto es 7 por 3 21 y finalmente
21 menos 4 es igual a 17 espero que esto
te haya dado buenas bases y te invito a
que realice los ejercicios que te voy a
dar posteriormente en los cuales podrás
practicar el evaluar expresiones como
estas